le nombre d'étudiants étrangers dans les
universités québécoises les universités
québécoises a bondi de 48% depuis 2013
ils étaient près de 33 milles en 2013
ils sont maintenant 48 milles la hausse
est marquée dans les programmes de
deuxième et de troisième cycle parmi les
raisons qui attire les étudiants
il y a notamment le coût de la vie les
droits de scolarité la force du marché
de l'emploi grossir et le doyen de la
faculté de sciences politiques et de
droit de l'université du québec à
montréal
bonsoir monsieur si elle reçoit alors
quels seront les effets de cette réforme
particulièrement sur l'aspect
universitaire les étudiants étrangers du
gouvernement legault selon vous c'est
une immense douche d'eau froide qui a
été projeté sur nos étudiants nos
étudiants qui sont pas en premier cycle
qu'à la maîtrise au doctorat
plusieurs sont venus ici au québec
étudié notamment parce que nous avions
des expertises particulières et aussi
parce que nous avions ce programme qui
permettait d'intégrer par la suite le
marché du travail la société
on a des étudiants qui y vont avoir fait
3 1 de bach
on leur a formé une bonne tête
ils sont intéressés à venir contribuer
ici dans la société dans notre économie
et on va leur dire non parce que ce
programme ce programme de l'expérience
québécoise permettait à des étudiants
étrangers de venir ici et d'avoir un
accès beaucoup plus rapide à la
résidence permanente
exactement ce que ça permettait de faire
c'est que après
la fin des études à la diplomation on
pouvait déposer une demande au québec et
on pouvait dans les terres d'un mois
obtenir un certificat de sélection du
québec ce qui acceptent ce qui
accélérerait la possibilité d'immigrés
de rester au québec d'obtenir au statut
de résident permanent
maintenant la plupart de nos étudiants
nos étudiants n'auront plus accès à ce
programme
ils vont devoir attendre possiblement
deux heures mais encore là deux ans et
là on va décider si oui ou non on les
invite selon des critères que le
gouvernement va fixer les chansons que
ces mêmes personnes qui n'ont pas été
acceptées
en vertu du nouveau programme ne seront
pas plus invités et donc ce qui va
arriver c'est qu'on va avoir financé des
étudiants pour faire leur bac
leur maîtrise leur doctorat on pourra
pas les garder au québec
mais toutes les autres provinces sont
intéressés à les accueillir parce qu' on
cherche de la main d'oeuvre la main
d'oeuvre qualifiée et donc le risque
c'est qu'on perd de nos étudiants donc
deux choses la première chose c'est que
c'est les étudiants qui veulent venir de
renavand au québec vont devoir composer
avec ce nouveau système qui est beaucoup
plus restrictif mais ça s'applique aux
étudiants étrangers qui sont déjà auquel
tu fais donc ça l'est un effet
rétroactif
on a des étudiants par exemple qui font
un doctorat en droit
ils sont ici depuis trois ans ils sont
venus parce qu'il y avait ce système est
là on leur dit ben vous pensiez que vous
pourriez intégrer le marché de l'emploi
ici tant pis pour vous si vous aviez
fait technique juridique vous auriez pu
rentrer et votre estimation c'est que
ces étudiants vont aller ailleurs vont
repartir dans leur pays d'origine
voyelles ailleurs au canada
ils vont aller ailleurs au canada en
fête l'ontario et le nouveau-brunswick
va les accueillir à bras ouverts que ça
soit on parlait d'intelligence
artificielle effectivement la
qualification informatique ne se trouve
pas dans la catégorie dans les
catégories accepter même intelligence
artificielle s'est aussi beaucoup les
sciences humaines et sciences sociales
parce que il faut comprendre comment la
technologie devra être intégrée dans nos
entreprises comment il va s'intégrer
dans notre société
et nous formons des gens en sociaux en
politique en économie
tous des programmes qui ne sont pas
couverts par la nouvelle mouture du au
nord du fait qu'on veut répondre
davantage aux besoins immédiats du
marché du travail
en effet et ce qu'on sent c'est que on a
fait une sorte d'adéquation en dix ans
un bac en sciences politiques devraient
former des politologues et par
conséquent on cherche pas de
politologues on en a pas besoin
ce type de raisonnement le qui semble
être à l'arrière de la réforme alors que
nos étudiants en sciences politiques
vont travailler dans différentes
entreprises dans les organismes
internationaux
on peut avoir par exemple quelqu'un café
sciences politiques spécialiste en
relations internationales et va aller
travailler pour les bombardiers de ce
monde va aller travailler pour la grappe
industrielle en aéronautique
oui cela dit quand on regarde les
étudiants étrangers à peu près 50 mille
présentement je lisais ce matin qu'on en
garde de 5 à 7 mais la grande majorité
repartent
oui mais c'est 5000 là ce sont des
forces vives dans une situation dans un
contexte où notre démographie la
pyramide est inversé nous avons besoin
de ces gens que nous avons formés qu'on
investit si collectivement dans ces
personnes pour qu'ils viennent nous
aider
une fois qu'elles ont étudié ils ont été
formés grâce à nos deniers publics
elles veulent à leur tour s'investir
pour nous et on va leur dire non voici à
l'epita nouveau brunswick calé en
ontario et en colombie britannique
c'est assez triste donc c'est un
repoussoir cela dit le premier ministre
aujourd'hui a semblé saisir
une partie du message en disant notre
objectif est quand même
et quand même pas de repousser les
étudiants étrangers on veut répondre aux
besoins du marché et on est prêt à faire
des ajustements donc il ya peut-être une
réception présentement à québec face à
cela on l'entend d'une réception
notamment pour l'intelligence
artificielle je m'en réjouis
par contre il rien sur l'environnement
et rappelons-nous que selon plusieurs
études ont dit 2030
il ya peut-être 40% des métiers qui
n'existent pas encore qui sont à
inventer et qui vont inventer ces
métiers là ce sont des gens qui ont une
formation une tête bien faite pas
nécessairement dans une domaine de
spécialité existant aujourd'hui mais des
gens à qui on aura aidé à se développer
à réfléchir de façon critique et c'est
ça à côté de ça qu'on va passer
merci beaucoup grossi réservé si bien